hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
one of Britain's only battery
manufacturers says it's considering a
move to the US in response to Green
subsidies
Exxon Mobil investors demand greater
transparency from the company over the
cost of transitioning to cleaner
Energies
and the Brecken beacons National Park
announces a change of name and logo in
response to climate concerns
thank you
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis
Sky News can reveal that one of
Britain's only battery producers is
considering shifting its manufacturing
to the United States the move by
anti-power comes after the U.S
introduced an unprecedented set of
subsidies for green companies as part of
its multi-billion dollar inflation
reduction act but here in the UK the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt says Britain has
no plans to compete with our own
subsidies for green Industries warning
that that could start a trade War our
economics and data editor Ed Conway has
this exclusive report
at the very northernmost point of
Mainland Britain just down the coast
from jono Groats and the lighthouse had
done it head you'll find a very
intriguing Place indeed
from the outside this might look like
just another industrial building but
inside you'll find a small group of
people making some very special
batteries
this place is one of the hidden secrets
of British manufacturing they've been
making lithium-ion cells here for more
than 30 years this Machinery was feeding
stuff going into military applications
now they've got exciting plans for the
future the problem is it's not entirely
clear that this country is the right
place to be putting them into action
why America is throwing money at
companies like this making green
technologies to come and make them in
the US
it's part of something called the
inflation reduction act a multi-billion
dollar set of subsidies for anyone
making these kinds of Technologies in
America raising the question why stay
here
we are a home-grown UK business we see
ourselves as a UK company we've
developed a technology here we want to
commercialize the technology here and we
want to manufacture the product here
that is our absolute desire we have to
ask the question if the subsidies are
available overseas and it's immensely
compelling arguments it's something that
we do have to consider but we want to
stay in the UK there's no question about
that
it's not just making waves on the
northern coast of Scotland
across the Atlantic in Richmond Virginia
you can feel the impact
when we're on a nice white roof like
this the sunlight can pass through the
modules secure solar has been installing
a raise like this for years but in the
past year Everything's changed
a huge uptick in interest from customers
looking to install solar you know we're
we're at the point you know struggling
to get solar modules because there is so
much interest in projects we've seen
we've had roughly a 50 jump in business
in the first quarter of this year
so what about the UK how is Britain
responding to the biggest shift in
American industrial policy in half a
century
the chancellor invited us along to some
of his meetings in Washington DC this
week here he is with the head of the IMF
talking about their economic forecasts
we're very focused on proven you wrong
excellent but uh thank you nice to see
you with companies threatening a green
Exodus is he going to produce our own
inflation reduction act if you depend
entirely on subsidies there's a risk
when you take the subsidies away you can
end up with a business that's not viable
and so our model in the UK is a
combination of of some support to get
businesses off the ground but then some
Market regulatory changes that mean
those businesses have a long-term future
and investment incentives through the
tax system
the problem is the clock is ticking and
with America having made an offer many
companies can't afford to refuse the
suspicion is there'll be yet more
businesses departing these Shores in the
coming years Ed Conway Sky News
let's take a look at some of the day's
other stories now in a coalition of
investors in the oil giant Exxon Mobil
are demanding greater transparency over
the costs the company could face as the
world moves towards net zero the
shareholders say they don't currently
have sufficient information to assess
the long-term risks and the economic
viability of the company in a carbon
constrained future
one of the largest reviews of the health
impacts of air pollution has found that
it causes damage to health at all stages
of Life exposure to small particles
emitted from things like wood burning
stoves road traffic and heavy industry
was found to be linked to stunted lung
development in children low sperm count
and miscarriages in later life it can
also cause chronic illness cancer and
strokes researchers at Imperial College
London reviewed 35
000 studies over 10 years to reach their
conclusions
hundreds of firefighters are battling to
bring France's first major forest fire
of the Year under control the fire has
torn through hundreds of acres of land
near the country's Southern border with
Spain more than 500 firefighters are on
the scene but Rescue Services say the
biggest Flames have now been contained
France is experiencing worsening
wildfires in the face of global heating
with last year its most damaging to date
conservationists are hoping to create
England's biggest native Woodland by
planting a hundred thousand trees in the
Yorkshire Dales much of the national
park was covered in Forest centuries ago
but now just five percent of the area
has Woodland cover that's less than a
quarter of the 21 in London the Woodland
trust charity says the project will
allow threatened local Wildlife to
thrive and help in the fight against
climate change
now the breckenbeacons National Park is
having a name change and will now be
known as banai braganyog or informally
the banai it will also discard its
burning Beacon logo as the park looks to
change its image to something more
aligned with its climate goals as well
as promoting the Welsh language joining
me now is Chief Executive Officer for
the breckenvegans national park
Authority Catherine meeling Jones
Catherine thank you so much for talking
to us so why this move to the Welsh
language name only
well um it's part of a whole package of
things which we're launching today a
long-term strategy 25 years out into the
future a new logo and um yeah and I
would say more of an emphasis on our
Welsh name which has always been there
um a spot of our ethos to promote Welsh
language and culture
do you think it's really needed if
you're looking at addressing serious
environmental challenges what will
changing a name and a logo do though
well as I say it's part of a package it
comes out today
um with with a long-term strategy with a
real determination to face head-on some
of the really big issues that we're
facing in the park uh the challenges of
biodiversity lost the impact on the
landscape of uh of carbon and climate
change
um you know okay in it on its own uh you
could say well you know what does that
mean but actually that that um that logo
is something which gives us an end to
talk to people who are visiting the park
to engage with local people which is
what we've done and through this process
of developing our plan
um and our and our revised identity
um and indeed the you know the the
previous logo isn't going entirely it'll
be phased out over time
um but it is uh very much more in
keeping with the whole 520 square mile
geography that we're looking after
um and as I say we're a landscape which
is very much about that interaction
between people nature and so on and we
have that will help people to engage
with those special qualities of the park
it's the second National Park in Wales
isn't it to adopt a Welsh Only Name the
verse being snowdonia what was formerly
called snowdonia excuse me how was that
received
um I think you know that it it divides
opinion somewhat I think um you know
ultimately I think personally it's
reasonably non-controversial to just use
the name the the Welsh name for a Welsh
place and that's essentially what we're
doing
um we're not uh insisting that people
have to use it uh we are as an
organization going to use it from here
on in
um and hopefully people will come with
us on that Journey but uh you know
people are welcome to have a go at the
name
um the the Welsh names are very
descriptive of places I mean is the
peaks of the king Kingdom of king
um and uh it's just a way in to uh to
understanding more about some of the
challenges that we're facing in the
landscape
um some of the solutions that we're
trying to inspire others to engage on
um and hopefully uh you know people will
get used to it if they don't I'm sure
many people for many years to come will
continue to refer to us as as the
beacons and and that's fine too what are
some of the biggest climate issues
you're facing in the park
um we uh we're facing um the sort of
interlocked twin challenges of um of
biodiversity loss and climate change uh
we're seeing a need for
um new green
um economy to start to flourish in the
park for uh sustainable farming and so
on for the ability to sequester carbon
through our large-scale peatland program
to retreat planting and that sort of
thing we're also
um needing to see a big shift from
um you know the carbon which is
generated through travel through
transport and so on it's a much more
sustainable ways of travel this the the
publication of this plan today is
um hopefully one of hope you know that
there are solutions to some of these
issues but we've got a long way to go in
in working with our partners to really
make a reality of the vision that we're
setting out the picture of the park in
2048 but what we were trying to do was
not to hide as some of the serious
issues that these beautiful landscapes
face and I think it's our duty to call
that out and to engage people on how we
can start to make things work in a
different way
okay Catherine thank you so much for
talking to us
thank you